One of the coolest things in the wind tunnel
is to see water floating.
Poured from a jug it quickly breaks up into droplets
the same sizeas raindrops
from around 0.5 to 4 millimeters in diameter.
And standing there
you can experiencewhat it would be like to fall with raindrops
They have a low terminal velocity of just 25km/h
that's what the wind speed was set to for this demonstration
andwhat you can see is that raindrops aren't shaped like cartoon raindrops
They are closer tospherical but a bit flatter on the bottom where they encounter oncoming air.
If a raindrop gets
too big,
it flattens out, caves in in the middle,
and briefly resembles a little parachute
before breaking up into smaller droplets